[Musica]
c'è un prima e c'è un dopo nella mia
vita legato a questo codice
questo codice 0 48 è uno spartiacque è
un prefisso telefonico
no non direi proprio identifica
l'invalidità sì a diversi livelli ma ha
un solo nome cancro nel mio caso uno di
quelli che ha già iniziato a camminare e
c'è una grande differenza da un cancro
peso sul nascere sia a livello clinico
che a livello psicologico
nel mio caso l'ho saputo per e mail e
prima è la mia vita fino a 50 anni una
vita piena di vita ricca di lavoro di
incontri di momenti durissimi ma anche
di esperienze fantastiche possibile
grazie alla mia ostinata libertà ea un
lavoro che mi ha portato i mondi diversi
svelandomi la bellezza della parola
dell'arte e della meraviglia la parola e
mia fedele compagna da sempre mi fa
viaggiare nelle storie della gente mi
aiuta a capire ea raccontare quando la
trasferiscono nei miei diari negli
articoli nei cataloghi nei libri l'arte
mia magliata mi sono tuffata nel
contemporaneo col desiderio di viverlo
più che di capirlo e di narrarlo l'arte
la parola sono mezzi potenti ci
raccontano e noi ci specchiamo in essi
ha usato l'arte e soprattutto quella
delle donne per affrontare argomenti
maledettamente serie latte fa volare e
non a caso ho scelto quest opera di
carla con le sei brilli che parla di
donne e di ali dino buzzati è entrato
prepotentemente nella mia vita
maestro della parola scritta è dipinta
assoluto nella sintesi nelle tavole del
poema a fumetti nel regno dei morti
il tempo è fermo non c'è più il dolore
non c'è più la speranza
manca la cosa più importante la libertà
di morire mi ha sempre toccato questo
concetto del tempo perché solo quando lo
perdiamo ci rendiamo conto del suo
valore
dieci anni dopo è stato il brasile ad
entrare nella mia vita
sognavo sempre di andare in una missione
mi ritrovai nel cuore del nord est in
cui sertao dove l'assenza dell'acqua era
in dari dalla terra e brutale l'uomo
dove la vita vale poco più di un panino
nella miseria più nera
i bambini sorridono sorridono sempre i
volti che ho incontrato le storie che ho
conosciuto dimorano nel mio cuore a 40
anni mi sono fatto un regalo
ho smesso di fumare non volevo vivere
con il terrore di morire di cancro ai
polmoni e così decisi di volermi bene
da quel giorno un acquista è più un
pacchetto di sigarette
dieci anni dopo quel cancro è venuto
ugualmente a trovarmi ma non nei polmoni
nel cuore della mia femminilità gli in
dove noi donne nutriamo la vita il seno
improvvisamente a 50 anni diventò un
codice 0 48 il modo in cui il cancro
entra nella tua vita
il tuo quotidiano è sempre improvviso
indiscreto travolgente cambia lo
scenario i tuoi orizzonti le priorità e
comprende il valore che ha il tempo ho
pianto
ricordo che la vita improvvisamente
cambia volto
eppure mi dissi subito terre non importa
quale sia il tuo destino
hai vissuto alla grande hai sempre fatto
ciò che desideravi improvvisamente non
avevo più un impianto ma a dire vero uno
l'ho avuto aver sprecato tanto tempo
prezioso con uomini sbagliati
non sapevo ancora quanto il mio cancro
avesse camminato ma sapevo cosa quel
referto avrebbe significato
chemioterapia radioterapia cure ormonali
chissà che altro
davanti a me scorrevano le immagini di
mesi difficili un anno fosse due forse
più il verdetto definitivo sarebbe
uscito dalla sala operatoria ma il duro
percorso delle cure era già una certezza
gli accertamenti controlli le ecografie
le risonanze scavano un buco in buco da
ansia ansia che è placata solo dalla
speranza che il tuo cancro non sia dei
peggiori c'è un mondo c'è tutto un
contorno nella vita di un malato che non
aiuta a stare meglio le facce cupe della
gente l'assenza del sorriso sui loro
volti i luoghi della malattia
alcune sale d'aspetto i silenzi l'odore
dell'ospedale
il caldo soffocante anche d'inverno
anche il tuo volto diventa grigio come
quelle sale tutti quei volti portano
marchiato un codice 0 48 il viso di un
malato di cancro pallido e cerio lo
riconosci tra mille anche il tuo muterà
giorno dopo giorno all'inizio lentamente
poi improvvisamente ti guarderò allo
specchio
in una foto e vedrai che è sfigurato
infuocato della cortisone senza ciglia
sopracciglia non sai ancora che effetto
avranno i farmaci su di te ma sei
bellissimo che a un certo punto
faticherei a riconoscerti bene in quel
letto di ospedale io ho aperto gli occhi
e ho capito poi pensiero mi assillava
dovevo trovare una soluzione e lì ho
capito ho pensato che per curare il mio
cancro dovevo partire dalla testa e
illuminarla con pensieri positivi
con pensieri nuovi in quel preciso
momento ho capito che dovevo diventare
io artefice della mia guarigione
ho capito che la cura ero io che la cura
sono io dovevo ritrovare la bellezza
quella bellezza che ho sempre
ostinatamente cercato dovevo restituire
bellezza la mia vita è così solo
ripartita dalla testa perché lì che
prende vita la volontà di volersi bene
ancora di più quando saprai che resterai
calva come sempre stato nella mia natura
ho iniziato a macinare progetti il primo
sarebbe stato
e mentre una linea di copricapi luminosi
belli allegri per me ma anche per tutte
le donne chemioterapia giurai a me
stessa che il cancro non mi avrebbe
rubato il sorriso
in quel grigiore pieno di ansia e di
paura
io col sorriso lo avrei sconfitto avrei
illuminato quel rigore con la luce delle
mie paillettes sulla testa è stata una
rivoluzione
vinsi la vita ossia di andava in
ospedale tre malati a fare la
chemioterapia con quel primo basco di
pajetta quella mattina in contrario una
giovane donna la sera mi scrisse sei
stato il mio brano primo raggio di luce
in questo percorso di tenebra compresi
che quelle pajetta avevano una ragione
di vita e di futuro non solo per me così
mi sono rimboccata le maniche e magari
fossi ancora nel pieno delle cure
nonostante la malattia ho dato vita ai
miei capelli ad arte una vera e propria
linea di copricapi sono loro che oggi
sostengono l'associazione ti ho chiamato
con mio credo la cura sono io
i capelli non sono semplici copricapi ma
molto molto di più
sono coop i pensieri che allontanano le
paure e portano il sorriso le idee
scintillanti i pensieri positivi dentro
ognuno c'è un messaggio destinato a una
donna che lo indosserà i copricapi
stanno sulla testa ma parlano al cuore
l'amore
avete al cuore e il cuore non si ammala
mai di cancro
ho cominciato
a comunicare tramite i social la mia
esperienza ed è stata subito
partecipazione empatia si è creata una
rete di donne che mi seguiva giorno dopo
giorno e con cui condivideva le mie
paure ma anche i miei traguardi
quotidiani era nata la mia grande
famiglia social quella che mi accompagna
da due anni quando dalla mia seconda
casa all'ospedale tenevo un diario la
cura sono io
crea legami diventa associazione
condivisione e tutto grazie a un
cappello la cura sono io sta contagiando
amiche amici tantissime persone che non
sono malate di cancro
lo ha fatto da subito quando con i miei
capelli andavo ai mercati in piazza a
raccontare che potevamo curarci senza
arrabbiarci senza aggressività trovando
dentro di noi delle risorse inaspettate
io per curarmi avevo scelto due strade
quella della dolcezza e quella della
bellezza e la cosa che mi ha colpito di
più sono state le persone che venivano
anche da lontano per dirmi semplicemente
grazie
non erano ammalate ma stavano
combattendo la loro battaglia quotidiana
e io tramite le mie parole di speranza
davo loro ottimismo
ancora oggi scopro storie di rinascita
grazie a quelle semplici parole e mi
commuovo lì ho capito quanto sia
fondamentale
in più per questo la cura di sé va
insegnata fin da giovani e famiglia
nelle scuole perché se hai cura di te
puoi avere cura degli altri e del
territorio in cui vivi
vi sembrano parole vane banali no sono
maledettamente seria e che la maggior
parte di noi le capisce davvero
nell'essenza solo quando viene colpito
da una malattia da una disgrazia che lo
porta a tu per tu con la morta e io mi
domando perché dobbiamo sempre aspettare
di stare male per cambiare la nostra
vita cura e avere dedizione premura cura
e responsabilità
la cura e il paradigma della mora non di
un amore sacro ma di un amore concreto
che diventa materia per cosa prendersi
cura di sé e scegliere di stare bene e
scegliere di stare bene
vuoi dire non chiedersi perché a me
perché è capitato a me significa avere
la mente pronto a cavalcare l'onda di
quello che accade adesso
ora bello o brutto che sia ricordando
che le cose dipendono da noi dal nostro
sguardo significa lasciare che le cose
fluiscano come viene natura influire è
il segreto della vita
e quanto più riusciamo a lasciarci
trasportare da esso più vivremo in
armonia scegliere di stare bene
significa dare spazio alla creatività
che mette in luce l'arte di vivere fare
immaginare sognare
solo così le azioni ci libereranno dalle
zone metalli dalle quelle sofferenze
dalle paure conducendoci laddove siamo
destinati
e portandoci a progettare bellezza
nonostante la vita ti sorprende
se tu le permette di esprimersi io non
avrei mai pensato che un cancro mi
avrebbe portato così tanti doni
oggi so che ogni mio passo ogni mia
parola in questa vita non è non sono
stati vani
tutti mi dicono ma lo sai che sei più
bella
io furia di sentirmelo dire quasi quasi
ci credo ma sapete qual è il mio segreto
vivo con la gioia nel cuore e anche nei
momenti più bui quella gioia illumina il
mio sguardo e ogni giorno
ringrazio il mio cuore che ora guida la
mia vita grazie
ma ripresa e ci dice che il cancro ha
dato inizio alla seconda parte della tua
vita
un po come se ora stessi suonando il
lato b del vinile e domanda è qual è il
ritmo che ora ci farai ascoltare ma è
ricco è ancora più rock di prima e
travolgente tutto quello che sta
succedendo nella mia vita però ogni
tanto bisogno di schiacciare un tasto
pausa e ascoltare una musica bellissima
importante potente e della musica del
silenzio
[Applauso]